the San Francisco Bay Area is home to
more than seven million people nearly
half a million of them are undocumented
immigrants it's also home to several
sanctuary cities which are meant to be
safer places for undocumented people to
live and that's caught the eye of the
federal government California better
hold on faith they're about to see a lot
more special agents a lot more
deportation officers in the state of
California President Trump is ramping up
ice raids and threatening to withhold
federal funding from cities that don't
cooperate with ice in the face of these
threats officials from sanctuary cities
like San Francisco Oakland and San Jose
say they'll still protect undocumented
immigrants at a time when local
officials are defying the federal
government just how safe is a sanctuary
City under Trump
[Music]
at the start of this year California
became the first sanctuary state in the
country when it enacted a law to
drastically limit state and local law
enforcement cooperation with ice and
here in Oakland the City Council took
things a step further in January they
passed a unanimous resolution banning
police from cooperating when ice is
trying to arrest and detain undocumented
immigrants the move came not long after
the Oakland Police Department received
backlash for an August 2017 raid in
which they provided traffic support for
ice now cooperation with immigration
officials in civil and criminal cases is
prohibited in Oakland that's the first
time this has ever happened in a u.s.
city
Oakland's mayor Libby Schaaf has even
said she'd go to jail to protect
immigrants so you're ready to go to jail
over this yes we are here to protect all
of our residents regardless of where
they came from the issue of sanctuary
cities is polarizing thanks in part to
Trump's repeated claims that they're
unsafe and hotbeds of crime he's pointed
to a high-profile San Francisco case in
which an undocumented man was charged
and later acquitted in the shooting
death of Katie Steinle right here on
this pier but the data shows that
sanctuary cities are actually safer was
significantly lower crime on average
there are 35.5 fewer crimes committed
per 10,000 people in sanctuary counties
compared to non sanctuary counties
undocumented immigrants in the bay area
are still getting deported
even from sanctuary cities although they
are safer jurisdictions whether you get
turned over to ice often comes down to
decisions made by local police take the
case of Pedro Figueroa as arson oh he's
an undocumented man from El Salvador who
was turned over to ice after coming to
this local police station to report a
stolen car he then sued the city for
violating its own sanctuary laws and won
a settlement but despite his legal
victory Pedro still in deportation
proceedings and although his settlement
was surprising how police handled the
case is not say you get pulled over for
a busted taillight or an unpaid traffic
ticket if police take you in your name
and fingerprints are automatically
entered
to the system if you're undocumented ice
gets alerted police can then hold you
for up to 48 hours which is enough time
for ice to come get you or they could
choose to let you go since Trump took
office the number of undocumented people
without criminal convictions who are
arrested by ice nearly tripled compared
to 2016 meanwhile California is not only
trying to shield 2.3 million people as a
sanctuary state it's also proposed
extending health care and financial aid
to the undocumented Attorney General
Jeff sessions called California's new
sanctuary state status unconscionable
and Trump threatened to cut the state's
federal grant money which the Democrats
called blackmail California is
technically the sixth biggest economy in
the world but that doesn't mean it can
afford to lose federal health so in
August of 2017 State and San Francisco
city officials sued the Trump
administration claiming the president's
threats to withhold funding were
unconstitutional and violated residents
rights
a federal judge agreed and blocked
Trump's attempts for now but despite all
the efforts being taken by California
and specifically the Bay Area to protect
undocumented people they still can't
stop ice from conducting raids or
deporting people already this year we've
seen major sweeps of businesses in
Northern California the largest such
workplace raids since Trump took office
and ice acting director Thomas Holman
has called for a 400% increase in
workplace rates making it clear that
even sanctuary cities aren't safe
California has shown it isn't backing
down from its sanctuary fight with the
federal government but for the people
whose lives are at stake the fear has
intensified as they wait to see how much
sanctuary they'll actually receive
hey guys it's Tina and we've done a lot
of reporting on immigration this season
check out the rest of the videos in the
direct from playlist and be sure to
comment like and share